president trump and former vice
president joe biden held their second
and as it turns out their last debate on
thursday night
and guess what a serious substantive
conversation actually broke out
it was almost normal without all the
histrionics of that first debate this is
radical left well you should listen who
is on your list joe
that was largely because of and i think
to the benefit of president trump
his hectoring and interrupting style in
the first debate was not a good look for
him in fact he dropped in the polls
afterwards he chose a different tack
this time president trump
i think we have to respond if i might
please and then i have a follow-up thank
you and i appreciate that
i think the question as a result is what
are the issues and themes that will
resonate through the
last week and a half or so of
campaigning that remains before the
election well i think there are four of
them
we're about to go into a dark winter a
dark winter
and he has no clear plan first you saw
joe biden continue to hammer away on the
coronavirus by saying
we have difficult times bringing the
coronavirus under control because
president trump has handled it so badly
he did virtually nothing and then he
gets out of the hospital
and he talks about where this is oh
don't worry
it's all gonna be over soon come on
there's not another serious scientist in
the world who thinks it's going to be
over soon
president trump your reaction over soon
i say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does this time he also said we can
fight the coronavirus better
without shutting down our economy
thereby trying to rebut one of the
republican charges on that front
we ought to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
safely open
second president trump jumped quickly
and hard on joe biden for saying
that it's time for the country to
transition away from the oil industry
because basically what he's saying is he
is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president biden let me give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have to
get to the final question vice president
biden
he takes everything out of context but
the point is look
we have to move toward a net zero
emissions
the president's saying that back stream
climate change policies from democrats
will debilitate the economy will hurt
jobs will hurt livelihoods
and cost people around the country
that's something you're going to hear
more in the closing days of the campaign
as well was nervous
before 47 years third you also saw
president trump hid away on what has
become a favorite theme which is that
joe biden has been a politician in
washington for more than four decades
he had all that time to do what he's
promising to do now why hasn't he done
it before now
now you're saying you're going to get it
done because you're all talk and no
action
we got a lot of it done that's a theme
the professional
politician joe biden versus the outsider
donald trump even though he's the
incumbent president
that will be a popular one in the final
days of the campaign
i ran because of barack obama because
you did a poor job
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run and finally you also
heard joe biden say essentially
i'm going to be the president of all
americans not just the americans
who vote for me that he can be a
president and a man
who unifies the country that donald
trump has so divided
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'm
going to be an american president
i don't see red states in blue states
what i see
as american united states so politically
of course does any of this move the
needle in the
campaign particularly a campaign when 47
million americans had already voted
early
before the debate even took place well i
think both candidates probably moved the
needle in the margins maybe a little bit
but mostly i think it was the kind of
debate that reinforced what most
americans already think
of these two candidates